jillian you've been on the red carpet of
the golden globes before this is a lot
different how does it feel tonight
i don't know i'm alone
in a hotel room in prague how late do
you plan on staying i mean are you gonna
make it through the night
i i at this strong sure i'm asking
myself that i've i slightly feel
sick to my stomach with nausea i'm so
tired
it's only midnight or it's only four
four
i see you got dressed up tell me about
your dress this is
a uh is this gonna is this illegal can i
do that
this is dior uh uh
yeah it's dior and and these are dior
was it a little strange getting dressed
up uh
and knowing you were just gonna sit in a
hotel room i mean i can't tell you all
the strange there's been so much strange
i don't even know where to begin yes
it's been strange
uh but but the dress looks good from the
from the waist up and that's all that
really matters
the dress looks incredible and and
speaking of incredible
you were incredible as margaret thatcher
what did it
mean to you to bring kind of a humanity
to um the late prime minister well first
of all that that was a wonderful
segue uh and uh second of all
i don't know i i think i think i
appreciated that
uh that the character as as written was
as complex and multifaceted as she was
and and perhaps more uh
complex than uh you know
the the the people of the world got to
see
the real woman um when she was alive so
um uh so it was for you know
complex and divisive characters are the
most
interesting characters to play so i i
was glad that it was
more well-rounded than perhaps who might
have expected
now you're shooting in prague right now
i am yeah yeah yeah
so how was that like you left set and
you're like maybe i'll come back
with a golden globe um i i'm not sure
whether i've actually played it forward
that much in my head
as to uh all i know is i don't have to
work tomorrow so
i don't have to wake up at 5 30 after
going to bed at five
so i'm very grateful for that how would
they deliver the have they talked to you
about how they would deliver the globe
if you win
apparently and i'm very disappointed by
this kevin is i i
there's not gonna be a man in a hazmat
suit sitting outside the door to give me
something i don't get anything
nothing you'll get one heck of a party
at like 4 30 in the morning
yeah that's the last thing i'm gonna
want but thanks
you know you talked about how different
and where this year it's been a weird
year for the royal family too
but people love the crown so much
it's like it's like a delicious food
what was it like going into that family
you know margaret thatcher isn't part of
the royal family
and uh and in fact she was uh
you know very much on the outside um
but going into the family of the cast
and the production of the crown was um
uh just a joy it's a it's a wonderful
wonderful production
and um uh and the cast was
spectacular and i felt incredibly lucky
from the very beginning
to the very end and you know headed by
the fabulous olivia coleman who you know
do something else julian i i am really
rooting for you tonight for two reasons
one
it was an incredible performance i've
been doing this for a long time
but also i want to see you in the middle
of the night
celebrating i want to hear this speech i
want to watch you ship
sips champagne in the middle of the
night wait wait wait
what yeah okay all right that's the deal
congratulations thank you